[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome
to this edition of bonehead of the week
gay boy did we have some boneheads this
week it has been a boneheaded type week
um speaking of your homemade shock um
one of the boneheads was susan collins
we all know she was terrified of chalk
and she had to call the she called the
chalk police yeah jim i don't report sex
crimes jordan showed up as a contestant
on bone of the week and then rand i love
vladimir putin paul
i think he also goes by uh
senator
rand
my neighbors hate my [ __ ] guts paul
oh well that that's a good nickname for
him too yeah yeah someone he has many he
has many different aliases or nicknames
and that's just a couple that we named
you know rand paul when he trends it's
really it's really crazy because like as
soon as he does something rand polish
which is
pretty much every day like he goes a
straight up to the top like he doesn't
[ __ ] around rand paul doesn't hover down
like at number 20 or number eighteen
rand paul goes straight to the top of
the trending people like [ __ ] this guy
we hate this this perm um debbie thank
you uh for the super chat have you ever
worked is that for me or is that for
tony who is that for i don't have you
ever let me i don't know that they let
me i don't know
like seriously don't come anywhere near
you say too many curse words to be a
substitute teacher and that that
probably wouldn't be a good idea debbie
um but i mean i don't know exactly what
kind of substitute teacher that we would
be but probably not in a school
where they could hear bad words that's
yeah
that's all i'm i'm guessing
uh dennis dennis michaels says john
melendez lies to your face is he related
to you proof by the coors on me i i i
know no i i don't know dennis
i thought he was like maybe your cousin
or something thanks for the super chat
um
i i we were on stuttering john's podcast
and he's got folks if you guys don't
know john john's got a lot of uh got a
lot of trolls out there that like to
troll him so because we've been on his
podcast they've been
they've been heading on over to uh to
our platform
tony tony and i've talked about this
like i mean i get a ton of hate on my
own stuff that i post online and tony
does too and so we welcome the trolls
here please
come and engage with the content let's
do it let's do it pump those algorithms
baby
pump those algorithms um
speaking of uh
pumping dude
who
i got i got to figure out
oh i see who the winner was because it
was really close wasn't it yeah it was
real close like how close was this race
here we're talking like
five percent difference between the
winners
of so across the polls because we yeah
across the polls yeah yeah but here's
the thing it was uh relatively the same
on you know the the numbers were a
little different but it was the same
choices roughly were made
uh between twitter and youtube so it's
interesting to see that oh i see so so
you're saying that the polls are pretty
consistent across the board is that the
i think elastic was pretty close and
today was uh i mean here what i'll say
is it even got a little bit closer um
maybe because somebody was trending
but you know
the end poll result on twitter was like
actually
two percent different
right so here is the contestants susan
collins jim jordan i don't report sex
i'm jordan and rand i love putin paul
here's the twitter results of course
this isn't the uh
the the the reflect oh i mean i guess it
might be a reflection but it is but it
is very close here you see i i'm kind of
disappointed
in uh the votes here that jim jordan
only received nine percent this bonehead
definitely deserves much more the nine
percent in this race um jim jordan has
been you know really conditioning
himself for years to be bonehead of the
week this should be
uh cause for concern for uh jim jordan's
career and in the bone head of the week
contest gabe i'm trying to do sports
commentary these yeah it's totally fine
i mean like here's the thing this week
was pretty close you know they were neck
and neck for
most of the race
uh i will say this when when the poll
was launched last night
uh i was following nobody voted for jim
jordan in the first like 30 minutes are
you serious
nobody nobody it was just zero percent
it was like it was almost 50 50 the
whole time from the beginning like when
i voted there were already 30 votes and
it was 50 50. oh man i i i'm afraid that
jim jordan's career um as a bonehead of
the week contestant boy this is this is
he's not looking he's falling off the
charts here yeah a little bit concerning
honestly you're right right he really
needs to step up his game maybe run a
few uh boneheaded laps yeah um you know
and maybe maybe maybe the film from
george clooney would help out jim jordan
for bonehead of the week
i'm super excited for that documentary
film good limited series whatever it is
as long as it exposes jim jordan for the
goddamn hypocrite
he that he is
keep in mind jim jordan hasn't passed
one piece of legislation while he's been
as representative for the state what's
legislation gabe what is this
it is um
is that something that legislators are
supposed to do then uh you know if you
look it up in the dictionary you know uh
yeah not not not easy on the dictionary
talk sorry if you look at republicans if
you if you open this thing that's full
of paper
right it's printed
on here it's got words in it it's got
words yeah that's okay so that's the
word
words
are a bunch of letters
that can range in anywhere from one
letter to uh you know long several
letters right right so and letters
though letters
are um
shapes
that are made
to form
uh uh words you know
you know it's i mean we can break it
down we can break it down even more you
know you know
in that book that you're talking about i
bet there is a definition for the word
dictionary in that book there's probably
yeah it's super meta yeah probably it
just says it just says this this yep um
and no one thank you for the super
sticker um also we have we have crows
here have you guys ever thought about
going to dc and asking republicans funny
questions it's funny that you would ask
that we actually talked to someone about
that on a show
um if you were listening and i think i
think you're alluding to that show
uh kathy also
with the with the uh super chat you're
gonna miss jinsaki uh speaking of um
of
boneheaded moves i actually i don't i
don't like the jinsaki's leaving do you
do you no no
i don't i think you know like i think
that i i think i think the sake bombs or
rather just the the the ducey dunks
we'll call him i'm gonna call him i'm
gonna call him a ducey dunk
okay the ducey dunks will continue
post gensake era so so we don't have to
call it a sake bomb anymore
i always i always think uh ducey as a
dump
but do you see dunks sounds pretty good
you know hashtag
i called it right here right now so i i
i i like jensaki i think she does a
wonderful job as the press secretary and
that's why i think it's a boneheaded
move but you know again i'm i'm not
calling anyone specifically a bonus i
just think it's a a bad move at this
point in time now um
they have announced that there is going
to be a new press secretary
um and and i think she'll do a wonderful
job too gabe you you actually uh posted
something congratulating me uh john is
it john p is that how what's what's her
last name um
jean pierre is that the john pierre yeah
i think she'll do a wonderful job too
brian john pierre yeah but the i i think
she'll do a fantastic job at the ducey
dunks but boy i'm just not ready
to call it quits on the sake bomb i'm
just well here's the thing i'm sure
because she's going over an msnbc so i'm
sure that the uh sake bombs will
continue and potentially a more
fiery format
yeah i don't know i i i just
was she getting her own show or she just
a correspondent i'm not sure i'm not
sure what the uh the deal is with the uh
with sake going to msnbc i think i think
again it's a bone-edited mistake
um if you want to know the truth i think
um she better serves the country she's a
very good press secretary she's uh
snappy she's witty she's smart and uh
again she not only dumps on ducey she
dunks on a lot of people and she kind of
puts the press where they where they
need to belong
um and and so i'm i'm i'm not excited
about her leaving because i i love to
watch the juicy the ducey dunks as it
will be from now on
referred
but the sake bomb was fantastic so i
hope i hope we can continue it and it's
not as boneheaded as it seems
so let's go to
i do uh
speaking of boneheaded stuff
so jim jordan obviously um we know the
reason why
he has uh showed up in this poll we were
talking about it earlier
because he is going to be
subpoenaed he's probably going to have
to appear before the january 6
select committee or he might be held in
criminal contempt is that your read on
this i believe kevin
i don't know exactly what the timeline
is if you just say here's the thing so
scott uh
scott perry right repair scott perry
yeah the guy from uh pennsylvania and
jim jordan
the reason that i remember scott perry
is because he was one of the people who
preemptively
said i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
participate i am not gonna testify i
will not work that with the january 6
committee like i'm not if just i'm just
not going to help them out at all uh and
i think that was
back in
earlier in 2020
late 2021 i think potentially like
december 2021
i think is when he made this kind of a
statement
but
now we look at this and these people are
i mean like you know bill barr is
another person
or not bill barr um
steve bannon is another person who is
holding contempt they have you know he
has a trial later this summer in july i
think if that hasn't been pushed
um
so i don't know what the timeline is if
you say no i'm not going to work with
you i'm not going to give you this like
then
how the whole held in contempt kind of
thing works out for representatives or
other people who are lawmakers on the
hill
yeah and and here's the news from scott
mcfarland at flash house select january
uh january 6 committee subpoena's
house gop letter leader kevin mccarthy i
think that's very significant but it's
also significant like you said jim
jordan scott perry mo brooks andy biggs
as part of this growing investigation
because this doesn't just mean that one
person as in kevin mccarthy the leader
but his lieutenants and then and all
this shenanigans
are going to be part of this growing
investigation
names that you see missing here and
pretty significant i think
um are some other names marjorie tater
green lauren bobert have they been also
subpoenaed or do you think they will be
i think
they will be
um
i don't think they have yet there's no
there's been no look at them but i i
would considering the fact that you had
people like margie taylor green who are
questionably you know
uh you know planning you know she had a
video where she was like oh we just had
a great meeting planning this you know
stop the steal and then you got lauren
beaubert who was actively you know she
tweeted nancy pelosi's location on
january 6th like i have a hard time
thinking that they wouldn't
uh
you know go after her
um or or both of them
so i don't know if it's i don't because
i also know that during the january 6
public hearings that they are not going
to bring everyone back
so i'm not sure if
they're gonna subpoena someone like that
to come in right beforehand
or what you know because there's no
guarantee again like if you deny and
you're like no i'm not gonna participate
in this even though you sent you you
issued me a subpoena like what happens
right do you get held in like capitol
hill jail or something no probably not
right right so they could easily just
flake on it and be like yeah i'm not
doing that at all
so i'm not i'm not exactly sure unless
they they have something that's pretty
damning where they're like oh i do want
to set the record straight
but i'm not sure so i want to move on to
the other
other contestant susan collins
we all know there's several different
reasons why susan gallons made the list
this week number one is um
she absolutely refused to vote to codify
roe v wade um but also
she basically she cannot recall she
cannot she feels bad
she thinks that uh you know
brett kavanaugh's telling the truth and
everywhere
and they learn their lesson and on and
on and on it goes with susan collins
something i want to show you here that i
found um
no
but this is it's close uh not quite it
says breaking susan collins is
introducing legislation to ban
high-capacity chalk magazines
um you see here i don't know i remember
this as a kid in school yeah yeah
we still had chalkboards when i was yeah
yeah i mean i remember by the time by
the time i got out
right on them the thing here too is i
just realized susan collins her her
initials are s
c
yeah sidewalk
chalk oh my god
wait a second wait a second wait a
second i'm just saying there's some kind
of space laser thing going on here i
don't know man i don't know but all i'm
saying is like when i break it down you
know sc susan collins sidewalk chalk it
seems a little bit suspect
this sus is [ __ ] such as [ __ ] um
so let's see if we can find here um
video
of sidewalk jack i mean susan collins um
what was that what was the video i know
what it was it was um
it was minus touch they had the video
what was it called the um
lying gop yeah lion gop is that what it
is yeah yeah uh she's in that one oh
yeah she's a featured she's a featured
celeb on that one for sure let's see if
we can find she doubled down
in several occasions to say that these
people would not overturn roe v wade it
was the law of the land and that uh
you know she could totally trust him and
so can you
um so if i find this video here it is it
is
uh let me pull this video up here and
we'll watch it real quick this will give
you a good idea of susan collins and
then then what we'll do is we'll move on
to our alpha cuck because i think gabe
really wants to move on to
getting to the alpha guy let's listen to
the lying gop from mind as dutch
i believe the constitution protects the
right to privacy
and i have no reason or agenda to
prejudge the issue
[Music]
roe versus wade is an important
precedent of the supreme court it was
decided in 1973 it has been challenged
on a number of occasions and the supreme
court has reaffirmed the decision when a
decision is challenged and it is
reaffirmed that strengthens its value
roe versus wade decided in
is the 1973
of the united states supreme court
it has been reaffirmed so a good judge
will consider it as precedent of the
united states supreme court worthy as
treatment of president like any other
[Music]
as a judge it is an important precedent
of the supreme court by it i mean roe v
wade and planned parenthood versus casey
been reaffirmed many times
casey is precedent on precedent
[Music]
i do not believe that here it is
presidents are overturned all the time
they aren't over turned off
don't you think he's probably going to
vote to overturn roe versus weight if
given the chance
i actually don't
[Music]
jesus out of me
please please save me from the chalk
please save me okay so susan collins
obviously she's afraid of chuck she's
also afraid of the truth
um and that's why she ended up
on the bone end of the week poll she did
not win though it was very close though
yep it was pretty close man i told you
when it started off you know first 30
minutes the first like 30 or so votes i
saw was literally 50 50. no one voted
for jim jordan
maybe maybe she'd learned her lesson and
when she does bone-ended [ __ ] she should
really ramp it up and she should really
ratchet up the bone-headed stuff and she
might have learned her lesson i don't
know uh the next the next the alpha cuck
that we have for the week is nick
fuentes nick fuentes
we went on a we went on a die raid the
other day about nick fuentes is that why
he ended up as alpha cup gabe is that
why you saw mick fuentes a hundred years
for the doctor a thousand years for the
woman is that is that is that the one
the main reason no no no no no that's
not at all it's also uh his projection
of uh because i haven't ever hooked up
with a woman that you're more gay than
me right because i've been celibate i'm
actually more straight than you bro yeah
that's that's kind of alpha kakish
doesn't it and then there's the other
video that i showed you that we pulled
up on the show which is when he goes the
most appropriate manner in which someone
could hit on him would be if there was a
subordinate in a workplace environment
where the secretary hit on him as the
boss
so nick fuentes really lives in this
weird ass celibate 1950s
uh
male dominated kind of scenario that's
what he wants he wants
back to 1950s woman barefoot in the
kitchen making the meal that would be
under the assumption that he could
actually get a woman that would
willingly want to engage with him that's
disgusting to think about um but yeah
those those three things and just him
being nick fuentes and being the the
nazi that he is right do you think do
you think that like his perfect mate his
perfect mate whether it's a female or
male
um would like spend late nights sitting
up reading mind conf with him exchanging
you know who i think would be a great um
just kind of you know a bunk mate or
just like a roommate or whatever matters
it that that could yeah
he's a fan of uh
he's a fan of of of hitler you know
right he went he went to the nest he's
like i went to the you know uh and not
only that but
he's also you know i don't i don't know
you know it's right like maybe they
would they would align politically and
maybe emotionally too right right and
even like if they were laying in bed you
know reading mind conf and that would be
you know
teabagging for each other super cute in
their own minds they look at this
totally
they say ah this is
this is what i've wanted all my life
just another person who loves him as
much as yeah
you know we're going to turn our
audience off here giving them an image
of madison gothard and nick fuentes
laying naked in bed reading each other
uh minecomp but let's see what yeah i'm
sorry i didn't want to make that image
but i'm just saying they seem to be
compatible
at least
emotionally well it could be and
interests well let's hear what nick
puentes says about women
who get
an abortion to save their life and
possibly the doctors that would
save that woman's life with a
with the procedure of an abortion let's
hear what nick fuentes has to say about
what he thinks should happen to the
doctor and specifically the woman the
woman should be put in jail too they
should all go to jail a hundred years
for the doctor
whoa
did you get censored bro what happened i
i think i think i did i think i got
censored i think i think did elon just
finish the deal did he just close the
deal is that what happened i know
i mean according to the eye guy which we
haven't seen any time recently the eye
guy told us that elon musk
owned twitter he did even though i told
him that he didn't he's right paperwork
doesn't say that he doesn't he doesn't
own twitter he still doesn't own twitter
and remember and he wants he won't own
twitter that's why we named our show
elon won't own twitter exactly and
that's the same reason why i shared the
video of him doing the financial times
panel and he said
i don't own twitter yet right and he was
talking about bringing trump back which
means that he also could potentially
bring back nick fuentes
if he were insane you're saying this
reality
this alpha cuck right here yeah bring
this alpha cuck back exactly that's okay
well let's listen let's see if elon
censors us again the woman should be put
in jail too they should all go to jail a
hundred years for the doctor a thousand
years for the woman that's what i say
elon wants to bring this guy back to
twitter and he wants to bring trump back
to twitter so the [ __ ] grabber and the
guy who wants to lock away women for
having a medical procedure right it
seems that scenes on brand for
for elon musk and speaking of uh elon
musk
he showed up as our dishonorable mention
at the very last moment
to the audience why
why elon musk ended up as the
dishonorable mention on bonehead of the
week right so as you guys know those
have been following you know tony was
like in the beginning he said
not going to happen this deal's not
going to happen from the first day on
the first day from the very first date
like even even even when even when there
was this the
slight stench
when when it was announced that he owned
like 15 and he wanted a board seat and
all that [ __ ] i was even saying this is
all [ __ ] well at that point at that
point i was like this well in the
beginning i was like this deal isn't
real this doesn't seem any any sort of
reality to it but then once the 44
billion i was like i'm 50 50 right now
it took me two days to look at
everything that was going on and then
come back to say it's not gonna happen
now since then we've learned of more
things that have come out he's got a
lawsuit against him as the ceo of tesla
because he has an agreement that he was
supposed to do a 10-year stint as a
dedicated ceo of tesla un undistricted
like not distracted completely focused
making sure that the company you know
grows and makes obviously the investors
and the shareholders the money that they
were promised right now what ended up
happening is that uh elon musk began to
get distracted he wasn't committed 100
of the time an investor came through and
had a lawsuit against him now on top of
that this twitter deal because that was
independent of this twitter that
happened before twitter deal came out
now once the twitter deal came out that
there was that that was actually going
to potentially go through that he was
spending 44 billion this investor was
like oh great this is more this is more
fuel for my own my own fire here right
now and then
the other side of it is that 44 billion
right now you have to look at where the
44 billion comes from and elon musk
doesn't have 44 billion to his name
which means the money has to come from
somewhere which means that most likely
the places he would actually sell his
stock and his shares to actually get
money to cover part of the cost would be
tesla and we've seen the downward spiral
i think the stock right now is oh i
don't know what it was it was yesterday
was like 735
it is going down month after month the
the the downward spiral
has lost the company billions it has
lost the net worth of elon musk billions
which is hilarious i would say that the
investors are pissed off here don't
think 100
and so these investors then you come to
the new lawsuit which is the orlando
police pension fund now has a lawsuit a
class-action lawsuit against elon musk
and the other twitter execs to say that
this this deal is not
in their financial best interests is
this the is this the the lawsuit that ty
ross wrote about i
the link to your article that you have
because it's it's a good article
describing is that's the lawsuit that
you're talking about right exactly that
is the one that i'm referring to and you
know yes the intel you know for this uh
odd elon this uh we got our little troll
here yes the entire market is down
however
tesla was moving downward before the
whole market had a whole downward trend
so
keep that in mind
and now you've got this orlando pension
fund which says we don't actually want
uh this to happen until 2025 right so
you know hey man you guys like the
police back the blue you should probably
support this lawsuit against elon musk
and twitter
then you've got that and then he gives
this talk at the financial times panel
where he says well i don't own it yet
i'd maybe bring on trump he'd be invited
but trump said he doesn't want to come
on which makes it seem like you know
you're like somewhat confident but
you're also
now stating publicly that you don't own
it yet despite the fact that other elon
stanza and republicans are also saying
that elon owns twitter and and that you
know he's finally uh freeing them of
free speech and blah blah blah and all
this [ __ ]
then
you find out last night the most
up-to-date
uh up-to-date in uh instance is that
uh elon musk says i'm gonna put this
deal on hold temporarily put it on hold
because what i found is that the numbers
of of twitter users isn't actually
accurate there's a five percent uh ratio
of twitter users that are actually fake
spam accounts
but mj pointed this out this morning
though and i brought this up earlier
isn't that the re one of the reasons why
he wanted to buy twitter was to get rid
of the bots i mean
he wanted to remove
he wants validation for the users he
says when you join twitter you should
have some sort of verification process
if you verify or you pay for twitter
blue you should get a blue check mark
all this [ __ ] but remember that
that is exactly right mj's right you're
right this is another case of point
where you look at this and you say
something doesn't add up if you buy
twitter for the purpose of making it an
open platform
a a town square as you as it will and
you want that to be pure
authentic real people
and you said that the way to do that is
like oh take a photo of your id verify
who you are it's going to be an actual
name in a photo it's not going to be
some random sock puppet account or
whatever
it does cause you to question what's
really going on here do you think he's
trying to avoid with some of this talk
yes and so that was and that was
something else that i try to avoid the
billion dollars is that what you're
gonna get right and so first first uh
this uh uh how do you say that uh auto
line i don't know what elon auto
um you may not be a troll this is uh not
a troll but way to lose a viewer ha ha
um you know you're still watching and
the other thing too is still commenting
right you're still commenting so you can
even stand here all day long and i don't
know if the viewers know this but we
handle trolls
uh a little differently and especially
the elon stand trolls we hand them a
little differently to most people they
would uh shut them out they wouldn't put
them on the screen
um that's not how we do it here we
actually believe in free speech we
believe in your freedom to say things so
this is i also want to point out that
i've been watching this guy talk in
various shows that we've we've had and
also today oh so you mean you mean this
isn't the first time this person has
been here to listen to this guy this i
would imagine it's not the last time
either oh yeah this person has been here
all day they've also been talking about
how we were wrong and they were saying
that 2 000 mules was evidence oh yeah
absolutely yes
well i mean obviously it's evidence fox
news would play it if it wait a second
maybe i'm wrong yeah so so let's get
back to the one billion dollars because
i actually think that is the most
important part of this entire deal right
that elon musk because he he's gonna
he's not gonna buy twitter he never
intended to buy twitter it was all a big
[ __ ] stupid gag to get this the elon
stands like this troll here that's been
listening to us for weeks about elon and
2000 meals um the reason why he's been
doing this is to pump them up and get
them excited and get them to to buy [ __ ]
and to pump stock mj kind of has alluded
to it over the last week and or two uh
as this has gone on when we've when
we've uh
conversated and engaged with people
online back and forth when i said from
the very beginning he is not going to
own twitter i believe the only thing
that elon is trying to do is trying to
buy time to find a way
to get out of having to pay another
billion dollars because he's lost all
this money and tesla he's probably going
to lose his uh his ceo ship i i think i
think it is possible within the next
year because of this deal and because of
the boneheaded stuff that he's done
because of this deal he is not going to
be the ceo of tesla he's pissed off
these investors he has proven to them
proven to them that he is not only not
only a [ __ ] [ __ ] and doesn't realize
that you can't just run around saying
whatever the [ __ ] you want to say that
you're going to destroy our investment
they're going to kick him off the
they're gonna kick him off well i mean
remember he was under investigation for
tweets that he said about tesla where he
just blew up he inflated the stock by by
promoting and you know saying certain
things on twitter still under
investigation still under or not
investigation but still under kind of
their overwatch which he tried to get
out of recently once this twitter deal
was announced and they're like uh no
dude you you're still kind of under our
watch
but the other thing too is like remember
i set it back on april 27th and there
were a bunch of people who [ __ ] hate
it on me i said elon musk has roughly
2.8 obviously well maybe less than that
now in cash and cash equivalents he
personally has to cover 21 billion of
the 44 billion twitter deal which still
is not secured and if anything all of
these events that have led up are
probably making the financial investors
the banks the vcs probably a little bit
skittish to say like i don't know if we
have the actual security to back this
guy right now
now there is the one billion dollar uh
breakup fee which by the way either
party has to pay if twitter backs out
they have to pay if elon backs out he
has to pay but he is now there
a rock in a hard place you know right so
he's trying to find any way that he can
and i think that's what his is uh
when this morning he's trying to use the
fact that there's so many fake accounts
quote unquote and to back out of this uh
one billion dollars i don't know exactly
what his aim is here right but i know
elon is a flake and i know definitely
elon will try to back out of any deal
that he cannot finish actually let me
show you let me show you some evidence
of that
watch this clip here he hasn't owned
twitter yet and he's a flake let me
prove it this is proof that he's a flake
i know this seems trivial here's a
picture of elon musk with a haircut look
at this here i'll make it bigger he
flaked on his haircut this is not a
finished haircut he did not even let the
barber finish his haircut look at this
guy does this look like a guy that
finishes anything come on give me a
break you know the thing about this clip
gabe
that i didn't realize after i made it
and posted it
i didn't say one curse word in that and
that whole group
they're like boom no band no suppression
you did it tony you did it i make
content without cursing [ __ ]
but you look at the situation right now
and yes i mean you know there's a lot
that elon musk has flaked on in the past
right like he has uh [ __ ] to bed when it
came to saving the the thai kids in the
cave he [ __ ] to bed when he promised he
was gonna give every flint recipient or
like resident
clean water in their homes right instead
while still good he gave filtration
systems to schools still not as great
because what happens when those kids go
home what happens when those kids are
out of school during the summer like not
really solving a problem here so you
look and there's there's also other
instances where where elon musk has [ __ ]
the bed or or made something up or has
uh uh you know kind of skewed what uh he
intended or what he said um
but remember one billion dollars a lot
of money twitter has nothing to lose
here right now they have everything to
gain either they get the 44 billion or
they get an extra billion dollar bonus
no they know this guy is gonna [ __ ]
run away and they're they're apt to get
that billion dollars right now i do have
to say gabe i i do want to give elon a
little credit here about his flake ship
um as i call him a flake because i i am
still standing behind 100 000 that elon
will never own
twitter as a private company he may own
stock but he will never own twitter as a
private company um you made this
thumbnail this morning saying epic fail
but i found this picture and sent it to
you and you used it for the thumbnail
yeah i had to go i did i remember the
video because it was on cnn i had to go
to the original source video
to get a higher quality to pull the
image yeah it was when it was after
paypal went uh you know they made their
money and he bought his million-dollar
mclaren is this is this a funny video is
it does it describe elon and
can we play them can you send me the
video yeah yeah because here's the thing
here's what i want to say about this
this photo of elon
i do want to say that his i made fun of
his haircut in the last clip but to be
fair the guy was dedicated
to
hair plugs he was dedicated to these
hair plugs
um i don't know how much if he spent 44
billion on the hair plugs or not
but you know
this is
a haircut that is worth getting hair
plugs for so i will give elon
credit
what credit is due to elon
but if we can find that video from cnn
now this is after he sold paypal because
he he was um you know he takes credit
for a lot of things that he invented a
lot of things which he did not invent
yeah um which we already know for
remember he did not invent tesla he did
not invent the electric car he is not
this savior hero person that
all these right-wing
you know uh or just elon stands put him
to
um
he is
also on hold on this is hilarious you
lib turds loved him three weeks ago for
what what did we love him three weeks
ago yeah i don't love elon musk i've
never liked elon musk i wouldn't buy a
[ __ ] i wouldn't i wouldn't own a
tesla if you [ __ ] gave it to me not
because i don't like electric cars
because well that's awesome because
today's sponsor is tesla
[Laughter]
brought to you by no [ __ ] tesla i mean i
mean here's the thing if elon musk is
not the ceo which apparently elon musk
is not even uh is working to not even be
an owner at tesla as much stock as he
has to sell to try to get into this deal
that he's not going to do
that he's going to have to spend a
billion dollars to get out of and then
he won't own as much of tesla as he says
he owns listen elon musk i if he doesn't
own tesla he's not the ceo i might
change my mind about tesla i might
remember that i won't this is something
i mentioned before is that
the position that he has at tesla as the
ceo is definitely at risk right you look
at what's been happening a downward
spiral downward trend of the stock value
which is the overall company value for
tesla you have investors and
shareholders who are not happy because
they're like where's the money coming
from to pay for twitter right
now
the the board
can have a vote of no confidence and i
want people to remember a vote of no
confidence means that the board can then
say usceo are not fit we do not have
confidence in you to continue in that
role you can still stay on that idea
what would give you yeah i know it's
crazy it's like almost like he was
distracted from the main focus for that
for making them money you mean their
money and their investment exactly and
he's gonna use that money to do this
little pet project
where what started as a joke and then he
figured that he was too deep into the
joke and he couldn't back out or else he
would look weak and now his ego was
frail and a little bit delicate you know
or always been delicate but a little bit
more tattered and now he has to defend
himself to be i'm the savior of free
speech but
also i'm not gonna actually go through
with it and i think at the end of the
day
and i said this in a tweet he's going to
put the blame on leftist he's going to
put the blame on twitter he's going to
put the blame on anyone else the box the
bots it was the bots it was the bots
even though he was the one who entered
into an agreement and he was the one who
said yeah yeah whoever whoever backs out
of this deal one billion dollars and
he's going to blame
litigate and say that actually
he was
the um
he was the one at fault and and or he
was going to say i'm rather not the one
at fault he's going to say everyone else
is at fault and i'm the i'm the victim
here i'm innocent i didn't do anything
wrong i had the best of intentions for
twitter and then he finds out that he
actually isn't gonna go through with it
all right uh ty ross says here um and
these are her words not mine folks
to be fair tony when it comes to
finishing the guy does have like seven
baby mamas so i don't know how many
babies mamas but it sounds it sounds
really trumpy yeah yeah i mean he's got
like eight seven or eight kids where you
know gabe the elon stands here just
pissed off in the chat here they're
really
good
they're really pissed off they're really
[ __ ] pissed off here in the chat here
and i i welcome them all
i i i welcome all the elon stands to
come and bump the algorithms uh make
sure you go to our twitter page
and really troll us there too don't just
stop at youtube please whoever this
baron von schneider is my god two
thousand years is getting a special
prosecutor yeah okay okay yeah
yeah that's i i believe that more than i
believe elon musk is gonna own twitter
actually i believe that way more than i
think any llamas speaking
let's play this video from um the
archived footage of elon's uh hair or
lack thereof let's let's let's listen
yeah some could interpret purchasing
this car as
behavior characteristic of a
materialistic breath here's yeah well
here's the uh there's the there's the
footage is that the one you had to pull
it from yeah oh wait is it spanish
well it's got the subtitles
that's the engine
and are you no i'm not it comes with its
own set of luggage actually or at least
it's not consistent with the rest of my
behavior
cnn.com
[Music]
oh look at that look at the phone oh man
he's this guy look at this guy elon musk
speaking emon
you know what this reminds him it looks
like the phone that derek zoolander has
he's like god
do you think he still answers the phone
like that probably he's gonna come off
he's like i don't want people tracking
me the other thing i want to point out
to all the elon stands out there this
guy's wearing a tan [ __ ] suit someone
someone someone get a hold of the deep
state this guy is wearing a tan [ __ ]
suit
i don't think he's on the side that you
think he's on or maybe maybe he switched
sides when he took his red pill oh boy
this guy's got a tan suit on this should
be concerned for the 2000 mule trump
bumpers out there
[Music]
i expect to receive a car that i've just
bought which is called mclaren f1
oh this is where so he's getting the
delivery of the car yeah and i will own
one of them it's a million dollars for a
car
it's crazy
it's uh it's decadent back in 95
there weren't very many people on the
internet
where's his pipe don't you think he
should have like oh yeah smoking here
like definitely definitely and he's
puffing on this is ridiculous certainly
nobody was making any money at all uh
most people okay i can't even i can't
even take it anyway that was the gist of
it he was there when he got his mclaren
and he was like it's a million bucks and
there's only 62 in circulation at this
moment i'm gonna own one of them right
so you know that's what happens i'm
gonna buy twitter i own one of them one
stock but i'm gonna buy it sounds
familiar i don't know it sounds funny
yep pretty much sounds sounds familiar
um let's go back to the um to the
boneheads of the week here now that
we've uh drug elon and the stands are
pissed off at us stick around stan
stick around stamps keep viewing because
if you do we definitely will [ __ ]
dunk on you when elon musk has to pay
the billion dollars to back out of the
deal
can't wait can't wait speaking about
backing out of deals that pay
pay money rand paul
um it ended up on bone of the week did
rand paul win the bonehead of the week
gabe
he did indeed he is the winner
of the week
um why was he on the bonehead i mean
there's so many reasons why rand paul
could probably well you know uh he's a
uh
he is a russian asset uh oh
pro putin
you know he's anti-life
pro putin
he's another he's another uh uh putin
puppet
and so when it came down to hey we
should help uh
uh ukraine defend themselves by giving
them money because you know there's
literal genocide that's happening
between uh ukraine
and from russians yeah i mean the guy he
loves is committing war crimes yeah yeah
yeah exactly
uh but rand paul was like uh you know
per usual uh
actually guys like he's gonna come and
he's gonna try to stop it
anything if he's gonna give back a real
science on youtube if you look at rand
paul's record you'll find that he either
is holding up people or he's the last to
vote
or he's the only one
potentially that is uh objecting
and um it is
not unlike rand paul it is very much
within his wheelhouse that is what he
does it's on brand he will for every
single moment that is against democracy
he will vote for it
well and uh it's not surprising in the
chat everyone can see in the chat that
that the elon stands are also pro putin
as well and they love rand paul which is
not surprising that they would love a
douchebag like elon musk
and stand for rand paul as well it is
not surprising let's go into the rand
paul thread here because i think it's uh
important for everyone to uh check out a
video and here it is
it's very easy to see because if if the
elon stands want to know out there why i
pulled evidence of why he's a flake and
why he wouldn't do the deal here's
evidence of the bone end of the week
winner rand paul
way back when a republican standing on
the senate floor calling him putin's
puppet
um long before vladimir putin decided to
commit war crimes in ukraine he was
being called and called out to be
putin's puppet let's listen
to senator john mccain
has no argument to be made he has no
justification
for his objection
to
having a small nation
be part of nato that is under assault
from the russians so i repeat again
the senator from kentucky
is now working for vladimir putin he has
no argument whoosh working for is what
he said um tai points may be a good
point out because this this uh elon stan
she's saying it's elon's burner account
elon might be in the chat folks i think
elon might be this
baron von schneider baron schneider
[Music]
elon's um alt account wow this guy's oh
i mean look you say what you want about
john mccain but he's saying brain tumor
john mccain is on par with these two
idiots yeah that's fantastic you know
look i'm not a i'm not a john mccain fan
at all really um if anyone wants to know
my stance on john mccain you can know
that my my adolescence for john mccain
stop
at his heroic dedication as a soldier
and a veteran to our country
um that's about where it stops because
he picked he picked the vice
presidential candidate that gave us
that gave us trolls like baron von
schneider their voice which is sarah
palin um so i don't have i don't i i'm
not a i'm not a john mccain fan yeah and
apparently john mccain was not a fan of
rand paul either especially
[Music]
rand paul who capitulates to putin and
who is working for putin um i have a
couple other tweets i want to show here
from our favorites um mayo has one here
let me pull it up uh she says rand paul
is a russian asset and a traitor to the
united states of america no lies
detected
you know uh mayo has a way of just like
just
just saying
just just just typing out exactly what
the truth is push and tweet
um and giving us all
an unfiltered way uh mj
with the super chat here ew oh here she
is she is giving a super chat in the
name of baron von schneider cheers to
that she says she loves your show loves
biden and wants to enlist in ukraine
army also says musk doesn't own twitter
and never will
thank you mj for the super chat and
thank you for keeping the elon stands
around yeah for the money for the money
uh what we love we love the elon musk
aaron von schneider over here keeps he
keeps
keeps throwing in comments but i'm sorry
baron you you don't realize that you're
only helping the video right now right
exactly but thank you you should you
should you know keep going put your dumb
ideas into the chat and help the
algorithm tell youtube yeah we should
keep promoting this thing to everyone
else on youtube so we appreciate it yeah
we appreciate all the help we can get
with the algorithms um
so back to back to rand paul so what
he's doing is he's holding up the vote
for this ukrainian effort yeah um to
actually beat back on vladimir putin
baron von schneider's
uh lord and dictator here uh
but really honestly
more than what rand paul is doing
because you remember what was it uh two
or three weeks ago he ended up on bone
of the week for the same exact thing do
you remember this do you remember what
he did yeah
why did he what didn't he do that he was
he was busy taking his [ __ ] and holding
up the vote for uh the for the scotus
nominee right um who was
brown jackson and but at the time
um he was just you know kind of like
twiddling his thumbs in the stall taking
a [ __ ] scrolling through twitter seeing
everyone that hates them you know not
finding a soul that actually likes him
outside of putin and the dm's that he
gets from him
but yeah he was he held up the vote and
then he came in and then was like nay
right which everyone knew he was going
to vote it was like literally the last
person everyone's like waiting like
jesus christ let's go man i want to get
to lunch right even on c-span they put
up on the screen we're waiting on the
[ __ ]
rand paul we're waiting we're waiting on
that [ __ ] uh kathy uh with the super
chat says what mj said oh
hell
super chat super chat um rand paul
is a despicable
despicable piece of [ __ ]
and um you know what i'm gonna play a
special video
for all of our um
our great elon stands here
um that probably actually absolutely
love
rand paul and what he's doing to help
vladimir putin
uh commit war crimes um
and you know some people were saying the
other day paige rand paul's neighbor
but i found this video someone had a
wish to a genie
and if they had one wish for a genie
what they would wish so let's let's
watch i grant you one wish
genie make me rand paul's neighbor
[ __ ] up so maybe maybe if there is a
genie out there
we could uh get the genie to make
someone rand paul's neighbor and we
could
settle rand paul down to stay off the
bonehead of the week but let's do this
gabe let's give him his due we are
running out of time
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you all for joining us for bone
end of the week including the elon
stands don't forget we will keep
dragging rand paul susan collins jim i
don't report sex crimes jordan and elon
i don't own and will never own twitter
musk on the bonehead of the week so go
follow us at tony michael's pod where
you can vote
you decide who is the bone end of the
week every single week and we break it
down for you
on friday in the second hour of the show
so don't forget to subscribe on youtube
at the tony michaels podcast just search
the tony michaels podcast you will find
it because we air every single week day
monday every day friday
noon eastern 11 central nine pacific on
youtube and what happens tomorrow tony
on saturday so to tomorrow we do the
best of the week and then sunday
speaking of bonus week on sunday we clip
out this bonehead of the week and we
post it all by itself not just not just
on youtube twitter twitch but also on
all your podcast directories so make
sure to find it there
on youtube twitter twitch the midas
touch facebook page and apple spotify
google
where you can give us a five-star review
that way to help us out with all these
elon stands leaving the bad regulations
but there's actually one more thing what
what this week yesterday we had an
interview with brent
and
we're also going to cut out that
interview so that people can watch it on
this weekend this weekend don't forget
to go to the youtube channel and watch
the full interview with brent there hewn
because we did have some technical
difficulties but yeah yeah it happens it
happens when you're doing a live
yeah whatever when you're doing a live
show
thanks for joining us bonnie of the week
stick around we'll be right back after
the song bonut of the week folks
[Music]
[Applause]